foreign
we have now proven in a culture that is
completely
soft coddled raised by helicopter
parents enabled
that you can be offended by almost
anything because you people are so
wisified out there I never dreamed
George that you would actually post an
Instagram about eating at home is
cheaper than eating out and you would
piss off half of the nation you know
that's how in the world is that
controversial you started the trend Dave
because you've always said I know but
how is it how is it that America is so
completely wussified that the idea that
you should not eat out if you're broke
causes you to be angry and hate George
unbelievable in their defense I have a
punchable face I understand no but not
for that you might get a punchable face
for something else that's what happened
this is just pitiful I did a a Time
George kick a swallower down I do enjoy
eating out even though I'm poor you need
to value your own time as if you're a
king it takes time to make your own food
you wussies you unbelievable little
children people
unbelievable I love I would watch an
entire show of Just Dave doing
impressions of the commenters this is
brilliant okay I don't even read
comments but they told me they were
vicious on your Instagram so I pulled
them up and I am laughing my butt off at
how pitiful you people are commenting on
this you are absolute morons this is
unbelievable here's what happened Dave
we our social team took a 10 second clip
from my talk at our smart conference
event in Dallas about the cost of eating
out and we're trying to help people find
margin in their budgets with inflation
so I'm just telling people hey eat at
home eat a new place called Mikasa and
if you want to save some money so James
play the clip so that everyone
understands why you were the most hated
man in America who knew this is how I
get canceled
the average cost of a meal right now is
13 bucks eating at home four bucks
so when you eat out here's the math
because I'm a nerd you spent 325 percent
more
enjoy that that was the entire clip and
uh it got 1.7 million views on Tick Tock
300 000 views on Instagram and most of
those were like hate watches because
they're angry and I will say Dave there
was one comment that was true it is 225
more it's 3.25 times more but 225
percent more so for the true nerds in
the comments I salute your extra math
there but for everyone else they're
going what was this the 1990s you can
eat out for my Taco Bell cost 16 uh
guys let me just tell you it's a simple
freaking formula if you run a restaurant
you pay the food cost
and you pay rent and you pay insurance
and you pay labor to cook the food
hypothetically and deliver it to one of
you people who have no idea that you can
actually cook at home apparently it was
shocking to your little systems that you
might actually engage in labor in your
own freaking kitchen other than your
crop unbelievable man my favorite is
people saying well Dave I saved so much
time when I go to Red have you been to a
restaurant you got to drive there number
one well here's the thing oh and I left
out profit yep and tip and tip well
these people don't tell clearly clearly
oh no this is unbelievable so here's the
thing I don't mind you eating at a
restaurant George doesn't mind you
eating in a restaurant but to say that
it is punishment
against your little soul that you
shouldn't eat at a restaurant when
you're freaking broke is so lucified
people that's ridiculous and of course
it's cheaper to cook at home of course
it's cheaper now I don't know if it's 13
versus four dollars or a hundred and
thirty dollars versus 50 bucks but a
hundred percent of you that can do any
level of math have to know that it is
cheaper to make the exact same meal at
home than it is at any restaurant you
are paying for the entertainment value
and the convenience of eating out those
things are called luxuries wimp that's
right and regardless of the numbers like
you mentioned Dave it's about the ratios
and no matter where you look online and
what numbers you pull up eating out is
going to cost three four five x what it
costs sure it does now here's the thing
these people don't understand Dave when
I said it's four dollars a meal I'm not
saying the meal for the entire family
was four dollars I'm talking about it
doesn't matter Georgia the only reason
they wanted pick apart your math is
because they didn't like your conclusion
that their little butt should eat at
home when they're poor you know it is
listen I've been poor and you know what
we we ate at home
or we were broke poor is a mindset
that's right broke as I'm passing
through okay but if you're broke you eat
at home
yeah you eat at home
and you eat the same thing again
tomorrow
dovers ooh gross I can't stand leftovers
me and Sharon Ramsey agree that we're
big fans of leftovers oh sure she won't
quit wears me out with leftovers to this
day because she remembers being broke
this is not going to waste and there's
stuff in our refrigerator is 83 years
old I mean it's got a mighty and we can
afford to eat out okay going to a nice
steakhouse tonight thank you Jesus all
right and I want you to go out to eat
I'm a big fan of restaurants I like
restaurant people I like eating out but
it is entertainment
and convenience it is not economic a
necessity for survival ever you never
eat out based on economics ever and it
is not an entitlement you wimp
and my time I may treat myself like a
king oh kiss my butt that is the dumbest
thing I ever heard in my life treat my
that say you sound like you're four
years old I mean what is your your
emotional maturity level there's no age
limit for Instagram Dave she could be
foreign
what kind of crap is that
kick you out you know what we're trying
to do is keep you from staying down
because you keep making stupid butt
decisions and that's offensive Dave it's
offensive to do be mature it's offensive
to actually have a longer mentality on
things oh it's like God I keep I keep
looking at these they just make me
madder and matter no matter the hour I
spent cooking is sometimes worth the
cost difference there we go it is
if you can afford it
it's no one disputes that the problem is
people are saying Dave I'm living Beauty
and me going out to eat tonight is
Sharon don't get any leftovers to add to
the refrigerator she might take a added
benefit but that's not an economic thing
that's they don't want any more
leftovers thing okay that's all that is
you know oh my God this can't be current
we've done the math as well oh you idiot
of course it's current it depends on
which meal set you're looking at and
what you actually bought and where you
bought if you're buying organic eggs
from a house chicken at stinking that
was you know it's not even a real
chicken and you're buying it at whole
whole paycheck at Whole Foods instead of
going down the regular grocery store and
getting regular cheap eggs you know you
could pay 18 for a dadgum thing of eggs
or you can pay a whole lot less for a
thing of eggs I mean it doesn't eggs
this is nuts it's insane and so yes
where you shop matters we talked about
that in the talk at smart conference go
shop at Aldi and buy it in bulk at
Costco and you can save big per serving
and people are saying you can't get out
of the there for yes you might spend 200
bucks at Costco but hopefully that feeds
you for two weeks if you want to
rationalize and justify anything you can
that's fine but there's no possible
thing you come off as as except inept
and immature when you start saying that
hey eating out is your right
and it's your life it's in the
Constitution your life is damaged kick
us while we're down oh my God
yeah I'll kick you while you're down
don't go on vacation if you're broke
people don't do it I made a woman on the
Today show that I was coaching cry on
National Television because she went on
vacation in the middle of me coaching
her and I'm like that's the dumbest
dadgum thing I've ever heard if you lost
your mind I told you not to do that and
she starts crying and I got trashed
because I jumped her case about dead gun
being stupid here's the next one you're
gonna get Dave Dave going on vacation is
cheaper than my rent so I'm just gonna
go on vacation it's cheaper
it makes about as much sense as this
stupid argument does
yeah and it's and by God it's my right
you can't just work all the time of
course you have to take time off you
work all the time when you're broke
that's what you do it's how you not be
broke anymore my grandmother used to say
there's a great place to go when you're
broke to work
you work that's how you fix them that's
how you fix the broke problem it's money
comes from work you work that's what you
do is it a way of life throughout your
whole life no but you little wussy you
go to work that's how you fix this you
don't go out to eat and you don't go on
vacation you're broke it's not a human
right
I am not joining
the glitching comments yeah entertaining
clown if you read comments on anything
you know why some species kill their
young I mean it's unbelievable wow